Hello?
Hello, hello?
Hello everyone!
Hello, Lieutenant Spicy, uh, Skull, hello Major, Michael, Spark, holy shit, who else am I missing?
Am I missing anyone else?
Michael, hello everyone!
We're gonna... gotcha!
Alright, uh, it's time.
It's time to play the spooky game.
Just until the eye is barely visible.
Okay.
Maybe I should just make it extra bright.
Maybe I should just...
Hey, TV!
Hey, hey, hey, sneaking on him!
Alright, maybe I should just make it extra bright so I can't be spooked.
I'm scared.
I'm actually... I heard it's not that scary.
I heard it's just, um... I heard... I heard that, like, it's not as scary as I... as... as, like, all the other games.
So that's why I chose this.
That's why I... I chose this game because I heard it's not as... not as scary.
Yeah, because it's just all, like, atmospheric.
I have no idea what this game is about.
I... all I know is that they're on a ship.
That's all I know about this game.
Um... but, yeah, I've never... I've never heard of playing this before.
Little Nightmares is so good.
I heard it's really good.
I heard there... oh, there are two mouse cursors?
Oh, no.
Where's the other one?
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay, I have to...
Alright, I know how to fix this, but, um... does it really bother you guys?
Okay, I'm gonna fix... it is gonna be a weird fix, chat.
I'll fix it real quick for the... for the mouse cursor.
Um... um... let me... chat, I'm just gonna fix the... the...
It's to deal with my Lepent.
It's to deal with my program, so I'm gonna fix it.
Technical difficulties!
I know.
We're always having technical difficulties here.
Um... so I didn't choose Outlast?
Yeah, I didn't want to play Outlast because I... it's really spooky.
And I've only played, like... I've played, like, three spooky games in my... like, two spooky games in my life.
And I'd rather not play... I'd rather not play Outlast, guys.
I'd rather go in.
Go in with the... the less spooky game for instance.
I don't want to go in right into... into, like, the most spooky one.
Um... I have... I have to fix it.
I'm... because of the... the mouse thingy.
It has to deal with my Lepent.
I have to, like, put it on the other side and stuff.
So... so... um... this is gonna... it's just me doing technical stuff real quick.
Uh... where's my... where's... oh my god, I'm so tiny now.
Holy shit.
I'm so tiny.
Let me fix this chat.
I... was it like this?
I don't even remember how... how it was looking.
Was it... the size?
Oh, I don't remember.
I don't... is this okay?
Is this okay?
Uh... bigger?
Is this alright?
Better?
I don't remember.
I already forgot what it was supposed to look like.
Was it like this?
Is this better?
Bigger?
We're not... okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Uh... take up the whole screen.
Okay.
Okay, like this, right?
Uh... there you go.
Perfect.
That's perfect, right?
Uh... yeah.
This is a very... very spooky video.
It's right in my face.
Alright.
I forgot.
Was it like this size before?
Also, I love you.
Thank you so much for the five bits.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Um... but yeah, is the size of... is the size of the model like this okay, chat?
Is this okay?
Okay.
I don't remember how it used to look like.
I already forgot, so...
Um... I think this is fine.
Um...
Alright, alright, alright.
Let's... let's...
Oh, pull it.
This is not what I wanted.
Whoops.
Technical difficulties again.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Embers!
Thank you so much!
I'm so happy.
I love you!
Embers!
Thank you!
Woo!
Thank you for the tier one sub for five months.
Can we get some bark knights real quick for... for... for Embers?
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Also, thank you so much for the 41 bits, lieutenant.
Thank you.
Alright,
let's start this game.
Let me check the settings...
Bible pump one, Bible pump one, one, alright, keyboard.
Alright.
Let's start this game.
Alright, let's go in.
Let's go in and play this game.
Let's start it.
Alright, good night, Spacey!
Thanks for stopping by!
Good night!
Well, we have a good night's rest for school.
Alright, let's... okay.
Okay.
Mentally preparing myself.
I just... I hear it's not that spooky, so...
So, let's pray I won't, like, fuck up.
I heard it's also a puzzle game, too, so...
Thanks, chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for making me use my brain yet again!
Of course you guys would make me use my brain in a spooky game.
I can't even see you shake my head.
I'm more scared of all these puzzles.
Our brain.
True, true.
We'll use our brain together.
Who the fuck is this girl?
Who are you?
Okay, you'll use your brain more in Visage.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
I'll donate my brain cells.
All of it.
Thank you for your kind donations, chat.
Can I move?
Oh, I can move.
Oh, there's the lighter.
Is there a timer on this?
Oh, I can pick shit up!
Oh, look at that!
Look at that!
I can pick shit up!
I found a can!
Oh, wait, I can't hold onto it.
Can I bring my can with me?
Oh shit, is this a puzzle?
Oh my god, am I gonna...
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
I'm building something here, right?
Okay, no, that wasn't it.
Hey, Crush.
Alright, I'm just gonna bring this with me.
I can't see shit.
Wait, I thought I could pick this up and use the lighter.
Hey, Mufi!
I can't wait right now because I'm picking shit up.
Oh, can I light this?
Oh my god, I'm so smart!
Maybe go a little bit smaller?
Oh, you want my model to be a bit smaller?
You guys want my model to be smaller, chat?
What are you doing here?
No, just a little bit?
Okay, let me fix it real quick, guys.
For you guys.
Just a little bit.
I'll just also move it over here a little bit more.
Alright, resume.
Alright, what the fuck do I do?
Oh!
Oh, push, pull?
Push, pull?
Okay, maybe I have to get my cat out of the way.
Okay.
Push.
Oh, pull.
Alright, come with me.
Come with me.
Wait, can I not bring it?
Oh my god, this is too... Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let me in.
Okay.
Oh, okay, I have to crouch.
I have to crouch.
Okay, I'll just kick it.
I'll just kick the can.
Okay, nevermind.
Fuck you.
I don't need the can.
I don't need the can anyway.
What?
Oh, I climb!
Rip the can.
I don't need you.
I look up?
Oh, what's this?
What's this?
Wait, can I jump off here?
What happens if I... Oh, oh, wait, you can!
I thought that would be an invisible wall!
Well...
Look, I thought, I thought, you know, there was an invisible wall, you know?
Like, you're... It was all just a dream.
You see her wake up.
It was just a dream, chat.
Stupid.
You guys think the fact that OO is just OO or OO is... What the fuck?
Oh, I can jump.
Wait, who's that?
Who's that?
I can pick you up.
I can pick you up!
Hey, little girl.
Oh my...
Oh, okay, no!
No!
I'm sorry!
I didn't know!
Can I push this?
Okay, no.
Wait, what?
What the fuck was that?
Wait, what the fuck?
It is Neil.
Why is everything so tiny?
The poor stat- You're gonna die now!
That was so bad, thing!
No!
Oh, toilet paper.
Okay.
Die here?
Oh no, there's a wall here.
Fuck, I have toilet paper.
Okay, I wanna read this.
Pick up the note.
Pick up the note- Oh my god.
I don't know what I can- Oh, can I pick up the shoe?
I can pick- I can pick up the shoe!
I can pick up the shoe!
Oh shit, wait, I need a- I need a- They take place in a 20- I can go for like $5000.
Wait- OH!
That's a bunny!
Oh shit!
Dude, I thought it was just decoration.
I thought it was just a long light.
Honestly.
I mean like- You know, I have my priorities straight.
I was like, look at the shoe.
And apparently there was- There was a body above me.
Clearly the shoe was a lot more important.
He was the long boy.
Wait.
I'm not spooked yet.
This is just a long walking simulator where I pick up shoes.
The shoe- Yeah, the shoe is more important than every- Oh, can I open this fridge?
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, there's- Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh shit!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come on.
Yeah.
Oh, there's more shoes!
Can I pick up the shoe?
Aw, it won't let me pick up the shoe.
So it's basically- It's basically just standing.
How do I- How do I climb up?
Fallen into the toilet.
It's just a long- Lieutenant!
Thank you so much for the Father Maple's knife!
Thank you so much for the- Thank you so much for the- For the gift and sub!
Thank you!
Can I get some bark knives real quick?
For Lieutenant?
For the gift and sub?
Oh man.
More like little shoes exa- Oh!
Wait, what the fuck?
I was gonna pick it up!
I was like, oh shit!
I can pick it up!
What the fuck is that?
Okay, now I know it's dangerous.
It's a dangerous boy.
Yeah, that's right.
What you gonna do?
Follow me?
Yeah.
Come on.
Yeah!
You can't catch me.
Yeah, what you gonna do?
Huh?
What you gonna do?
Yeah?
It's gonna kill me one day.
I'm gonna...
Um... I'm gonna leave.
Oh, is that another one?
Oh, that's another- Oh, that's more.
Oh, there's too many.
Oh, they're all following me.
Joke's on you guys.
I live.
Is that a shoe?
Oh, wait.
They're following me.
You're not dropping?
Okay.
Oh, they don't drop.
Huh?
Let me...
Oh, it doesn't do shit.
Okay, I was gonna be like...
What you gonna do?
Kill me?
Pull...
Pull?
Climb?
Oh, pull!
What
the fuck is that?
Woah!
No!
Ok, hahahaha!
Hahaha!
Ahahaha!
Where am I?
Oh, I start here.
Okay.
Oh no.
Wait, no.
No, get away.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
How do I get?
Push, push, push, push, push.
Okay.
I hear this game is like two to three hours long, so I'm going to finish it in an hour.
I bet they're whispering for anything.
That's so nasty, right?
Oh, the sub goal.
Oh, I forgot to swap it.
Oh, what are you?
What are you?
I forgot I was supposed to say 400 instead of three.
I forgot to change it.
How do I climb?
How the fuck do I climb?
Please.
Oh, you hold on to it.
Okay.
Can't...
What?
What do I do?
Oh.
Apparently I can't climb.
I'm all used to climbing chat.
Okay.
Okay, I was going to be like, where's the lights?
What
the fuck?
There's a fall damage here?
There's a fall damage.
Why the fuck is there fall damage?
Oh, wait.
Dying to save time on the run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's fall damage.
Okay, look, I have a bed.
Okay, please don't touch me.
Please do not touch me.
I had fall...
Oh, wait.
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know there was fall damage here?
Okay, I gotta get past this checkpoint so I don't have to do that again.
Also, is the sound okay for you guys?
The sound of the game?
Oh, oh my god, what the fuck?
I forgot about that.
Because I don't know if you guys can hear the game sound.
Because it's like very atmospheric.
Okay, alright.
Where do I go then?
Okay.
Oh, do I jump?
I jump, right?
I jump.
That gnome is actually moving.
Okay.
Push.
Hey, Bippie!
Oh, oh, oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, and then I run.
And then I run, and then I run.
Can I sprint?
Oh, wait, you can sprint!
Why did no one tell me I can sprint here?
I've been fucking walking this entire time!
You can sprint in this game!
Hey, oh yeah, yeah, there, yeah, there.
You can sprint, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
How the... how the fuck?
How the fuck?
Wait, do I jump here?
What if I get dive and fall damage again?
Okay, okay.
Okay, by the way, there's fall damage.
Okay, okay, okay, let me see.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh!
Now it tells me!
Now the game tells me that I can sprint!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
Now it tells me!
Okay.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Oh my god, dude, I'm so fucking good at jumping.
I told you that the last two times!
I didn't... I didn't see... I didn't see...
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh, it just lets out the gnome out.
Where does it take me?
Wait.
Is there a point going up?
Oh, no, there's not.
There's no reason for me to climb that.
Oh, you're gonna scream.
Whoa!
That gnome is fast.
Okay.
I'm so fucking good at jumping.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh, what was that?
Oh, oh, oh, okay, guys!
That chocolate man down!
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a... have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Oh, shit.
Do you have seven feet tall iron mouth?
Let
me in.
Wait, what?
Let me in.
What?
What the?
Let me in.
What?
No!
Please!
What the fuck?
What the...
Oh, damn it.
Oh, god.
Are you free of the world record?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't believe I've only been playing this game for like ten minutes.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck is that?
Hey, my curious.
Okay.
Okay, how do I...
How do I...
Let me in.
The fuck do you want?
Oh, okay.
I don't know how the fuck I got in.
I don't know.
I don't know how I got in there.
Boom.
Let me in.
Oh, look, there's rats.
And there's toilet paper.
Can I take these toilet paper out?
Oh, I can't.
Toilet paper.
Oh!
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
That's bad.
Electricity bad.
So what's supposed to be... I don't know.
Apparently it's like atmospherically scary.
But... oh, light.
Give me light.
Light.
Eat the rat.
Apparently it's a good game though.
But I don't know what's scary about it.
It's just puzzles.
It's just like a spooky puzzle game.
But it's the first scary game.
So we're starting it...
We're just starting it with a timid game.
I don't know if it'll ever be really scary because it just makes the mood so much lighter.
I don't mean to.
It's just... I don't know.
I'm just too stupid to make it seem scary.
Like...
Why is the hair so tiny?
Look around by using...
Wow!
By using arrow keys...
Oh shit!
Oh!
I was like...
Oh shit!
I'm looking.
I'm looking respectfully.
Hey.
How do I get up though?
I looked.
What do you want me to do afterwards?
I'm looking.
Where are you?
Oh, there's something behind this.
Oh!
That's what I need the toilet paper for.
Toilet paper.
Just jump?
Did you know you can look around?
Okay.
Like bad.
Wait, there's a timer?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, let me through, let me through!
Hey.
Okay.
There's bloody hand prints on that dresser.
Oh, there is!
Look through my hands!
There's a... oh, wait.
I can pull!
Oh, I can't.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can pull.
I... I... I... No, stop picking stuff up.
Oh, oh, oh.
I can't... I can't walk now.
Okay.
Okay, what do I do here?
Oh, hey.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, wait, what am I supposed to do?
Do I dive and do this?
Okay, no, I won't.
You're gonna like... you've been on a bed.
I don't know what to do here.
Oh.
I'm just pick... hey, look.
Smoking.
I can pull.
Pull.
Oh, come on.
You can pull.
Pull.
Pull Up.
Up.
Okay, not up.
Okay, the fuck?
Okay.
Ugh.
Okay, what do I do up here?
What is this?
I'm looking respectfully.
Oh!
Oh, I have the speedrun!
I have the speedrun!
Okay!
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry, I'm the best at speedrunning.
Alright, alright, look at this.
Bam!
I'm fucking running.
I'm fast as fuck.
I'm fucking... Please, please stop fucking... I'm the best.
Oh my god!
I'm tripping over everything.
I'm fast though.
Look at that.
I'm so... Oh god.
Please stop tripping.
Holy shit, I'm so...
I'm zooming.
I'm a zoomer.
Oh my gosh, look at that.
I could've died.
Haha.
I'm a zoomer.
I was born in 2010.
Wait, what's that?
What?
What the fuck?
Is that water?
Well, how old would I be if I was born in 2000?
I'll be like 10 years old.
Wait.
Yeah, I'll be 10 years old.
What's up?
What's up with steel?
Boom.
I don't know what's the point of all these... Not TOs.
Okay, sorry.
I was born in 2007.
So that would make me...
That would make me 13.
So I won't get banned.
Okay, wait.
I realize I should not... What the fuck is that?
I realize I shouldn't say that.
You could clip that out of context and Twitch will actually think I'm 13.
Or like 10.
I am legal age to be streaming on Twitch.
What's that?
What is that?
Oh, oh, no, no, no, no.
You can't see me because I have this thing.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, it's an eye.
Okay, I came fast.
I'm fast.
Oh, oh, jeez.
I'm fast, I'm fast.
I'm fast as fuck, I'm fast as fuck, I'm fast as fuck, I'm fast as fu- Are those dead kids?
Are they dead?
I'm fast as fuck, I'm fast as fuck, I'm fast as fuck.
Okay,
I wanna like this.
This won't hurt me.
Yeah, I can't find me.
Stupid.
Boom.
I don't know what that does, but I just want it.
You're really a zoomer?
You were born before 2010?
What's that?
Is that a little gnome?
What are you doing there?
I'm gonna... oh.
Oh.
Wait, do I pull?
Pull.
No, no pulling.
Do I climb?
Oh, I climbed!
Climb.
Should I free that guy?
I'm gonna free him.
No, you know what, fuck it.
I'm not here to do achievements.
Fuck you.
I don't care about achievements.
No.
No one cares about him.
Look, hens.
Is this my bed?
No, not even- I'm gonna jump at her.
Do I jump?
Jump.
That must be an achievement somewhere.
Hide?
Do I need to hide something?
Oh!
Wait, wait, is this another statue I can throw?
Oh, it is!
He's our-
Oh, I jump!
Right?
I look, wait.
Okay, no, I don't jump.
There's nothing there.
Is it actually bad to destroy those statues?
I don't fucking know.
Push?
Where do I go?
Let's see.
I think it's just achievement stuff.
I don't care about achievements.
I'm just here to get a speedrun.
I'm gonna finish this game in an hour, chat.
I can't believe I've only been playing for like 10 minutes already.
I'm just here to get a speedrun.
Do you know that the humming noise is slowly getting faster?
What humming noise is?
Don't check under the bed.
Don't check under the bed!
Bye.
Wait, wait.
Where do I go?
Wait, where do I go?
Let me in.
Up?
Where do I go?
He doesn't know.
I don't know where to go.
Oh!
Push!
Pull!
Wait, there has to be an entrance here.
Push!
No, no, no.
Pull!
Wait, no, no.
Up?
What the fuck?
Where do I go?
Wait, how do I push you?
How do I push you?
What the fuck?
Where do I go?
Oh!
Up!
Up, up, up.
Up here.
It's up here.
I'm so good at this game.
Alright.
She's reading it out.
Okay.
Okay, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
Down?
No.
Oh!
Oh, I'm hungry.
I'm hungry.
Me too, man.
I'll pick this up.
Okay, I need food.
Try to surprise her with brain cells after you took them off.
Is there like a...
Is there like a time...
Like...
Is there like a timer?
Because of how hungry I am?
Or can I just...
Hey there, kid.
Give me your food.
Hello?
Hey.
Hey, give me your food.
Yeah, it's me.
Hey.
Oh, he gave me food!
Yeah, that's right, Sim.
Okay.
What a fucking Sim.
Yeah, that's right.
I ate your food.
That's right.
Is he gonna stare at me?
What a freak.
Oh, he's crying!
Yell, little bitch!
Yell, you little bitch.
I'm gonna cry.
Wait, where did I go?
No, he's just miming.
Oh, shit.
I wonder if that little kid shows up again.
Dude, I'm zooming.
I thought you guys said this was...
What are you doing with this?
I thought you guys said this was scary.
I'm sorry.
I killed you for eating his food.
Oh, okay.
So, I don't need this.
Can I push this off?
Shit, where do I go?
Oh, up.
Can I go?
Alright, why are you open?
Open up.
Why do you eat your food?
Next time, then it'd be a horror game.
Oh, I actually thought I was gonna fuck that up.
Can I go up here?
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Stop falling.
I don't want to fall down, actually.
Okay, okay.
Where do I go after this?
Stop?
Oh!
I go up.
Open up.
Okay, well...
Can I just keep going up?
Okay, I would die if I jump off from there.
I would die if I do that.
This is fine.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I guess I...
God, please don't.
Please, please, please.
How do I...
How... how...
How... fuck.
Oh, here?
Yeah.
What the fuck was the ladder for?
What the fuck?
What was this ladder for?
If I could just use that.
Oh, thank you so much for the follow.
Cold Railgun.
Thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Have a butthurt.
Thank you so much.
What the fuck was that for?
Excuse me?
Please.
What?
And then... push?
Oh.
Huh?
What?
Oh, oh please don't.
What is this for?
What are you for?
Where do we go?
Trigger... what's trigger of COVID?
Don't die.
Oh shit, wait.
Oh.
Wait, then how do I turn this lever?
Wait, what?
Oh hey.
Then how do I turn this?
I am... I'm so confused.
I do this and then I run?
I run... oh I run.
Oh I'm so fucking smart.
I'm so fucking smart.
Oh ho ho.
Hmm.
Enjoying Little Nightmares so far?
I think... like... I thought it was spooky.
I think...
like...
I thought it was spooky.
But it wasn't as spooky as I thought.
It's just a little bit of a nightmare.
It's just... it's just atmospheric.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the...
Look at that!
Marshall!
Thank you so much for the tier one.
Six months!
Woo!
Can we get some Berk night material quick for Marshall?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Like, I thought it would be like more spooky than I originally thought.
But at the moment I'm not spooked at the moment.
Oh.
Yeah, that's right.
This is the first...
This is the first spooky game.
So we'll gradually get spookier each stream.
Each variety stream.
Okay.
Let me up.
And then...
Oh.
Okay.
Not like that.
Okay, not like that.
Okay, not this.
No, I'm not gonna play Outlast.
I...
Oh, my hand!
What the fuck?
I didn't even notice it.
It's just a tracker.
It was just a tracker.
No, I do!
I do have my hand here!
My tracker's working up!
I'm sorry!
Okay.
Alright, is this a nice speed run?
Would you play Alien?
I don't know.
I think I'm gonna play Visage after the next stream.
Visage is scary, right?
I wanna gradually get scarier.
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, that's the news!
Is Visage scary, chat?
Oh, who are you?
Little bitch?
Alright, we're gonna play Visage next stream.
Cause I wanted to gradually get spookier each game.
But like, I'm going into each game blind, so I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Like, I don't know what the fuck is...
I don't know what the story is!
I just know I'm a little girl.
I'm just a little girl.
That's all.
Oh!
I'm a little tiny girl.
Fucking running around at a ship.
And I'm hungry.
I'm hungry.
Like...
Oh.
Get over the highway.
I can run.
I can...
I'm a little girl in a yellow raincoat.
That's all that matters in life.
Oh, I just need to go through here.
Why am I climbing?
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh.
Here we go again.
It's okay.
Oh!
No!
Wait!
I thought that hit me.
Okay.
I can zoom.
Alright.
Puzzle time.
Zoom.
Oh shit, I can slide.
Whatcha gonna do?
Huh?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
I wasn't fast enough.
I wasn't fast.
I didn't zoom hard enough.
Okay.
Whatcha gonna do, huh?
That's right.
This is what...
This is what she's like to be up here.
I had a bad time as a kid.
There's a thing where like, um...
You're reading a book or something like back then when you don't have like iPhones or whatever and then your mom comes in or your dad comes in and you like fucking hide your book or your Gameboy underneath your covers and pretend to sleep.
That was me.
I did that line.
Is there bunny hopping here?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm bee hopping.
Wait, wait, I think...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I got it, I'm so good.
Not even close.
I'm bee hopping.
The scariest moment when you realize you knew they were... wait, yeah.
You can hear their footsteps outside your room and then you're like, oh fuck, and then you hide here.
You're like, whatever you're looking at, underneath your covers or under your pillow.
And then, close your eyes as they come into your bedroom.
Hey Nocticity.
I'm not spooked at all, I'm just vibing.
I'm just bee hopping.
I'm not spooked.
Oh.
God damn it!
I thought that was where the staircase was.
Okay, anyway, I'm not spooked at all, I'm just bee hopping.
Did you hear him fall?
I thought that was where the staircase was.
Can we go here?
Oh, hey there.
Do I like this?
I like you.
Ooh.
No.
Did I just open you?
Did you learn different footsteps?
Like, I know my mom's footsteps patterns and my dad's.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did that.
Like, I would know if it was my mom or dad coming into my room.
This... what?
This doesn't take me shit.
What?
Wait, what?
Why can't I go through?
Let me through!
What are you?
What?
Oh, I need to push.
I need to...
Push?
What?
Is...
Am I supposed to go through here?
Push?
Oh, fuck this.
I don't care.
Okay, I guess we don't go this way.
Wha- wha- wha- what was that?
Wha- what's that sound?
Wha- Wha- wha- what is that?
What the
fuck is that?
Hey, Juki.
It goes through now?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Come on!
Okay.
Are you gonna open again?
Are you gonna open?
It's closed.
What?
You guys heard that, right?
I'm so confused.
Well, I think I can go up here.
I'm pretty sure.
I can also go up here.
Okay, I don't know what the fuck that room was.
That was- that was spooky though.
Can I open this?
No.
There's a pressure plate?
I don't know!
I don't know what the fuck that was!
Like, also thank you so much for the follow, Ravioli!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a- have a butthurt.
Thank you so much.
Wait, really?
Okay, let me check.
Let me look at it again.
Let me look at it.
Let me- Let me see that again.
I'm- I was curious.
That- that spooked me.
I bet you that's what they do to speedrun this.
They do little bunny hops like this.
No, there's no pressure plate here though.
Oh!
Oh, there is!
You're so smart!
Holy shit, look at- Wait, then what the fuck do we do upstairs?
There it is!
But, what about upstairs though?
I don't know where to go.
Do we go up or here, chat?
Which one should we try?
Okay, let me- let me bring this light down.
Should we go up or right?
Here?
Okay, let me bring you with me.
Maybe this is heavy enough.
Okay, okay.
Okay, where does this take me?
Button?
Hey.
What's this?
Stupid.
Oh.
Oh, no!
What is this?
Oh, I remember this!
I know this guy!
I've seen this guy before!
And like, when other people were playing this game, I remember seeing the creepy chef.
This is all here before.
Oh, who are you?
I'm not learning nothing.
I- I think this is for like, plot and stuff, but I'm- I'm not really learning anything.
Is that it?
Oh, is this plot?
Oh, shit, this is plot!
So like- wait, what the fuck?
That's new.
What's this?
Plot.
Wait, what?
Oh,
what are you?
What the fuck are you?
Okay, bye.
I- I guess I was learning plot the entire time.
I have no idea what I learned today.
Oh, no!
No, fuck!
No!
I'm back here!
I- I am- Is that a thing to- To do plot again?
Oh, gives up to you.
But not .
So.
Photoshop, thank you so much for the- for the photo!
Thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Have a fun work.
Thank you.
.
I'm not really able- What did I learn today?
Also devil.
Uh.
I'm freaking nut.
Okay.
Thank you so much for the follow.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Also have a blood heart.
Okay, do I have to do plot again?
Plot.
I don't know if it's like a thing that I have to...
No, we'll do plot again.
Let's go.
We usually have some Bortle, right?
Alright, plot time.
I don't know if it like keeps it.
Does it keep it?
Oh, no it doesn't.
Okay, okay.
Speedrun plot.
Speedrun.
We're speedrunning.
Please, let me keep pressing.
Hey, Jackie-san!
Alright, I'm gonna plot.
Alright, done.
We spedrun plot.
We've learned.
We've learned about her past and where she came from.
Okay.
I'm gonna go back up.
Have I learned from my mistakes?
Not really.
I have not really learned.
Oh my god, you can't see that?
Wait, wait, let me do that again.
Oh god.
This is supposed to be a spooky game.
Boom.
Oh, can I open this?
No.
This girl has mad endurance, right?
She's like strong as fuck, apparently.
Like, look at that.
What do I do with you?
Clutch?
Okay, not like that.
Oh!
Chew.
Oh, I should have pushed this over there.
Okay.
This is a bit slow.
Is that a dog?
Holy shit, that's an u- like, what the fuck?
Wait.
Is that- is that- does he have a freaking dick as a nose?
Chat, you see that, right?
Like, what?
You guys see that?
I just- oh, wait, no.
That's not a dog.
Wait.
I thought it was- I thought it was a dog.
I just had to look closer.
It was- I don't know what the fuck that was.
But his nose was a big peepee on Angie right there.
Is it timed?
What are you speaking?
Does this mean the complete opposite for me?
Okay.
Where did I go?
Here?
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no!
That was not where I go.
Oh, I have to push it again.
No!
Why couldn't they just give me the suitcase where it was?
I wonder how far we are already in this game.
Because it's supposed to be a two to three hour game.
And I'm already- I've already played this game for ten minutes.
Why is it so spooky?
It's supposed to be spooky.
What's the spooky noise for?
Okay, clearly the light has no meaning.
Oh shit!
Who you?
Who you mister?
He doesn't have hair and he's wearing a hat.
You know what I say?
We don't need hair.
Just wear a hat.
He's okay.
He looks okay.
The fuck is his eyes now?
Oh!
Oh no no no!
Did I turn you on?
What?
Hey.
Okay, I guess I do that again.
Because I fucked up.
True, I'm probably almost done.
Oh, there's a key.
There's a key down there!
I didn't see the key.
Where do I use the key then?
Okay, key.
Boop.
Key.
Bye.
Okay, I thought I died there.
Okay, where do I use you?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Okay, where do I?
Do I know?
Where the fuck do I use the key?
Uh.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do do do... do do do...
Did I fuck up?
Am I not supposed to eat this?
Wait...
What do you do with you?
Uh...
Suitcase?
No...
Okay... I don't know what to do with you!
Key!
Uh...
Key...
Key?
Okay, I feel like this key... there's nothing... I feel like this key... there was nothing to do with this key.
I just brought it down for no reason.
Okay, I go back...
You'll figure it out, I'm figuring it out.
She's learning those notes as Danny promises.
What do I do with the key?
Where is the lock?
Okay, wait, if I look up?
No...
No?
I'm looking...
Boom...
Okay, do I go up here?
Hey...
Oh... no... no... no, no, no!
No!
Pfft!
Where is the key?
Where...
Okay...
Okay, maybe here.
Oh, you can climb up this!
Oh...
Oh... is that a dead guy?
What the fuck is that?
What are you?
Oh, it's just pants.
It's just...
That's...
It's just his pants.
Okay...
What do I do here?
Oh, I'm alive.
Oh...
Where's the key?
Where... where'd the key go?
Oh my god!
Can I push this?
Oh, why did you just kill me?
Oh, my god!
Oh, my fucking god!
Oh...
I got...
I'm...
I'm dead.
I...
I hit him.
Oh...
No!
Oh my god, she was climbing up!
Alright, give me the key.
Give it to me.
I'm a baby.
I'm fucking...
Here we go.
Look at that speedrun chat.
Look at that.
It's not like...
It's not like I died or anything.
Hey, Eddy!
Yeah, I don't need you.
Stupid key.
I'm so fast.
What do I do?
What?
Do I chuck you?
Uh.
Oh.
Wait, can I just push this open?
No.
What the fuck do I...carrying an object hold... Yeah!
I did!
What the fuck?
What?
I'm chucking!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Come on!
Oh my god.
Now it works?
I don't know.
I don't even know how far we are, Embers.
Are we pretty far in this game?
Please tell me we're pretty far.
Please don't tell me we're only 20% down...done with this game.
There's no way.
There's no way there's more to it.
I don't know.
We're still in the dark.
I've never...yeah, I've never played this so I don't fucking know.
What?
Can I push you?
Uh.
No?
I'm in a box.
We passed Longboy from the...
in the baby thingy.
In the baby thing.
There was like a bunch of babies and we passed him.
What the fuck?
Did I bring you back?
Alright, where are you?
I'm bringing you back.
I don't fucking know what we're doing with you.
I don't know.
Do something.
He's not doing anything so I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
I'm climbing.
I'm...
Where?
What do you want me to do?
What do you...
His mirror's light getting brighter.
What the fuck?
I'm just stuck here.
Oh!
Oh?
Okay, no.
Wait, no?
No?
Please!
Okay!
I'm just bad at aiming, I guess.
I'm just... I'm just bad at aim.
Did he bring you?
That's so smart.
Okay, are you hungry again?
Oh, you little bitch.
Alright, don't worry.
We'll get you food.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm gonna get you food.
Don't worry, please just keep jumping.
Oh no, please, please.
I'm gonna get you food.
Please just walk for...
Oh, I can't jump anymore.
I'm too hungry.
Hey, metal.
Oh shit, is that me?
Oh god, that's disgusting.
Oh
my god, what the fuck is wrong with your hands?
Oh come on!
Oh, I'm gonna get you food.
Clefie, thank you so much.
We're gonna fly in minutes.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
What is he...
What is he doing?
Let me out.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's looking right.
I'm leaving.
Bye.
Yeah, I don't give a fuck about the little other people trapped there.
They're each their own.
I just go here?
Oh, okay.
I do not go there.
Okay, we learned that...
that I do not...
Oh my god, you're gonna make me watch this...
I'm sorry!
It's gonna make me watch this cutscene again!
I won't do it again!
Okay, alright.
Alright.
Okay.
Well, now I know.
Now I know.
Okay, I know...
we go through here, right?
Okay, what the fuck do we do now?
Oh, thank you so much for the follow as a fa...
as a... as a...
I'm so sorry!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much.
Okay, what do we do here?
Do I wait?
Okay.
Okay, I don't wanna jump off again.
I don't wanna jump off again.
Go back inside?
How do I...
Little bitch.
Oh, I use you!
I use you for my own good.
I use you for my own gain.
I see.
I see, yeah.
Cry.
Okay, so there was like no point in going other than achievement shit.
Okay.
Let me climb up.
Let me... I don't care about you.
Let me...
I don't care.
Let me climb.
Let me... Oh, there we go.
What?
Please, let me... Please, I don't care!
Let me climb.
Tiddy, thank you so much for the 29 bits!
Come on, please.
Please.
I'm sorry.
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much for the 29 bits.
Okay.
Okay, let me push you...
Okay, I'm very bad at directional shit!
I don't know where the fuck this is.
Oh.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, I need to keep holding.
I need to keep holding.
Okay.
And then we'll swing.
And I'm gonna swing.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I got this.
Boom!
Boom, boom, boom, boom!
Yeah, that's right.
I'm so good.
Where did I go?
I made it.
Push?
Come on.
Come on!
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, wait, is that a thing here?
Oh, that's not...
Wait, wait, wait, here?
No.
What the fuck do I do?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Okay, if all else fails, just keep going up.
Just keep climbing.
Oh shit, is this a guillotine?
Why the fuck is there a guillotine here?
Oh.
Let me in.
Boom!
I got in!
Oh, look, there's bodies.
What is he gonna do?
Oh!
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
No!
Oh, you little bitch!
Yeah, you're so stupid!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I don't know where to go.
I don't know where to go.
Wait, wait, no, no!
I'm sorry.
I don't know what to do after that.
Okay, now you're gonna fucking do...
I keep forgetting.
I can't do it.
Thank you for the... for the... for the... for the 31 bits.
For the 31 bits.
Thank you, thank you.
XSML, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Wait,
I got this.
First try.
Please, please leave.
What?
Please, just leave.
Okay, okay, first try.
Alright, that was just a dream.
That was just a dream.
This is the try.
If I keep doing it, I'll succeed.
I just need to keep doing it.
I just... I just need to keep running.
Please.
No!
How do I get this?
How?
Where are you?
Do I need shoe?
Shoe!
Thank you so much for all the...
Oh, this... this... I don't need shoe.
I don't need shoe.
I didn't need shoe.
Shoe!
Thank you so much for the bits!
Oh, ah!
Please, please, please!
Please, please!
You didn't know.
I'm still fucking smart.
First try.
Oh my god.
First try chat.
Oh my god!
Dude, stop giving me shit!
Shoes!
Shoes.
What you're supposed to bring me, cute?
I got it for nourishing me with spit.
I need to hydrate.
I need to hydrate after that.
Mmm.
Okay.
Got this.
Look at that.
First try.
We didn't die at all.
I'm more scared Doki was screaming.
I'm screaming right now.
What do you mean?
I never screamed in my life.
What the fuck are all these shoes?
There's so many shoes.
Look at all these shoes.
I can't even jump.
There's just too many.
Oh!
What are you?
Let me up.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
Let me look.
Oh.
Okay.
Please.
Let me up!
Let me up.
I gotta get up.
Oh my god.
There's so many.
So many shoes.
Please.
No.
Yeah.
That's right.
I can't.
Yeah.
That's what you're gonna do.
Huh?
Okay.
Where do I go though?
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
We're 75%.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alright.
I got this.
I'm sprinting.
Boom.
Please.
No.
Yeah.
That's right.
You little bitch.
What are you gonna do?
Huh?
I thought I was gonna fall off.
I honestly thought.
What do I want?
Well you can't do a thing!
Oh!
What the...
I like it the fuck!
Please!
No!
Why?
I was through!
I got through!
It was cheap, guys!
I have to do it again!
Okay, I know what's gonna happen this time.
Yeah, slide.
I'm sliding.
Yeah, you can't get me this time.
You can't get me this time.
Please.
Yeah!
You can't get me!
Wait.
How do I do...
Wait!
I don't have anything to close this!
Please.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know!
No!
He doesn't...
Wait, did he got me?
Did he got me?
Oh, he did!
He did!
I'm got you!
He's gonna knock you down!
And you may come to tarnish it.
Okay, okay.
We got this again.
We got...
Okay, okay.
Boom!
It can't get me.
I'm fast as fuck, boy.
That's right.
You can't scare me again.
You can't scare me.
Please.
Please, don't touch me.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, don't touch me.
I know.
I know what to do.
I know what to do now.
Hold.
Yeah!
I'm in the box.
I'm in a box.
Can't get me.
I'm sorry.
I got stupid.
Can't see me.
Stupid.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's right.
Fuck that gnome.
That's right.
I'm safe.
What did I join into?
What the fuck is that?
Snake battle.
I think we have like a clips channel.
I'm pretty sure.
We have a clips channel here.
Where am I?
Do I need to throw this again?
Uh.
The fuck?
Oh my god, Dylan.
Thank you so much.
Dylan, thank you so much for the tier 1 7 months.
Woo.
Can we get some break nights real quick for Dylan?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
How goes the stream so far?
Dude, we're fucking speed running it.
We've only been playing this game for like 20 minutes.
And we're almost done.
Isn't that crazy?
I have no idea what I'm doing right now.
I'm just pushing this box.
Yeah, I haven't died once or screamed at all.
Wait, do I just push this?
Push.
I don't...
What?
What do I do?
What the fuck?
Hey, Chris, the 11 man.
Push.
Wouldn't probably as well let that one slide.
Oh shit, here?
Jump?
No.
Alright, alright.
I'm trying to figure this shit out.
I'm using my brain here.
My brain is expanding.
It has to be down.
It is down.
How do I get in you?
Oh!
I sent a screenshot on your Discord and I blame you for...
for... for... for reading testosterone.
What do I do?
Get down.
Oh!
Oh.
I'm so smart.
Oh?
Oh, here we go.
Oh shit, look at that.
What is he doing?
Chris the 11 man, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
What does she do with them brain cells, right?
Can I just leave?
I don't wanna go.
Stupid.
Oh, he's so creepy.
He-he-he.
Okay, I'm gonna lose this fucking spoon.
It's gonna leave.
Can I leave?
Oh, look, there's a dog.
Oh.
Is he gone?
Oh, he's gone.
What the fuck do I do?
Okay.
We've been downloading a few months, basically flipping for a lot of time.
I'm gonna go home now.
And Stacey, you know what?
I'll finish downloading now.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
It looks like a Freddy Krueger's blind cousin.
He doesn't have hair.
He wears a hat because he's bald.
Does he just want me to climb up?
I'm not climbing up!
Dude, what the fuck?
Am I supposed to wait?
Oh, fuck it.
What's he gonna do?
Kill me?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
We have to go down, down!
I heard that.
I was like, I'm going back down.
Wait, he doesn't play?
Wait, wait, where am I supposed to go?
Okay, okay.
We're gonna let him kill me.
Kill me first.
Because I have no idea what I just do.
Yeah, come back here.
Stupid!
Okay.
Am I supposed to sneak?
Just...
go...
sneak through...
Whoa!
Just...
Go!
What?
Wait!
No!
You're not stupid!
I'm sorry.
What the fuck is that?
I'm sorry for calling you stupid.
I don't know where to go.
Oh,
he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know!
Okay, maybe he knows.
Where do I go?
No, she didn't.
He might know.
Doesn't say anything else to say about it.
I'm trying to fucking figure out where to go.
I don't know where to go after.
Where the fuck do I go?
What the fuck?
I accidentally called him stupid.
Now he's mad.
Okay, okay.
Where do I go?
She doesn't know.
I don't know.
No!
Please!
Stop!
No!
I don't know!
I thought I'd jump in slow-mo.
I don't know where to go!
Alright.
Okay, maybe I'll work one...
Please!
I'll work one day!
I'll get out of this hell!
Believe in me!
Okay.
Alright.
Do I go like this?
Ugh!
What do I do?
What do I do with you?
Oh, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
Okay, he knows.
Okay, I think he knew.
I thought I could camouflage!
There's so many of me!
What do I do?
What the fuck do you want from me?
What do you want from me?
I've gotten so many things through work.
Okay.
Please.
Let me climb.
This.
Let me climb!
No!
Please!
Let me climb!
One day, let me climb!
Please!
I just wanna climb!
Okay.
I got this.
I got this!
And we're getting closer!
We're getting closer!
Okay, maybe I just need to throw the monkey farther away.
That's it.
The monkey just needs to be farther.
I just need to throw this monkey farther away.
Ugh!
Here we go.
Yeah...
Wait!
What the fuck?!
Why are you so fast?!
He heard me?!
Holy shit!
Come on!
You don't even have ears!
You don't even have...
Okay, maybe.
Okay, you do because you can hear...
Oh, you do.
You actually do have ears.
He does have ears.
Okay.
It'll work some day.
We just need to keep trying.
I...
I just...
We know what to do.
You hurt the monkey?
Monkey!
Go for the monkey!
Is the monkey too far?
Monkey too far...
Here we go.
Monkey!
No!
Yeah...
No no no, please.
Please!
Please, please, please.
No, you don't know where I am.
You don't know where I am!
I just wanna... I just wanna climb!
That's all I wanna do!
Please, just let me climb.
I fucking hate you.
I... there are two... I fucking hate you.
I hate you so much.
Okay, there are two monkeys.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
I'll figure this out.
I'm fucking so smart.
Bam!
I'm gonna figure it out.
Mark my words, I'm gonna figure you out.
Is this a monkey?
Please, let me climb.
That's all I need to do!
I just need to do two monkeys!
Two monkeys!
Please, please let me through.
Two monkeys.
It's so easy.
First try.
I didn't think that would work.
Boom.
God, I'm so smart.
Two monkeys.
Wait, wait.
Who are you?
Wait!
How did you get here?
What did you do here?
First try every time.
Oh, oh, oh!
What?
Take that!
No!
Not me!
What?
Zero.
You haven't died yet.
We haven't died yet.
We were just...
This is brother.
What do I do here?
Do I- Is this?
What is this?
Can I climb up this?
No.
Ok.
I need to like, figure out what this is.
What is this?
What are you?
I'm so confused.
Did I push this?
What are you?
What the?
Ah!
It's easy!
Just don't die.
Oh shit, you're right.
You're right.
Okay.
I do this, and then I go WOOOOOOAH!
And then...
I don't know.
I don't know what to do after this part.
He doesn't know.
I'm in the dark.
He don't know where I am.
I'm in the dark!
Do we not just go... Maybe go forward.
Maybe I don't go backwards.
Maybe I just go forward.
Like a like a normal person.
Maybe I don't run in a dead end.
I feel like maybe I should just went forward.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
That wasn't it.
Forward was not the answer.
I'm so wet.
I had to do a hard clicking puzzle and now you want me to do another hard puzzle?
Back to back?
What is wrong with you?
I need to recharge my brain.
Okay.
Maybe.
Maybe I take the shoe and I throw the shoe.
Give me your shoe.
Give me the shoe.
No!
Let me throw this first.
Let me.
No!
Poki!
Thank you!
Poki, thank you for the rain.
Hi Poki.
I am...
Thank you.
I had a good stream.
Hey everyone.
Hello.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Casey, Rainbow, Julian.
Thank you.
Have a... Have a good heart.
We are doing a spooky game right now.
But it's not as spooky.
I just...
My brain... I just need to figure out puzzles right now.
But welcome everyone.
Welcome.
Also thank you so much for the follow.
Seko and Kongu.
Thank you.
I do... I do appreciate.
Thank you guys.
Have some more blood hearts.
Thank you.
Um... We are stuck on this.
We are stuck on this.
On this puzzle right now.
Big brain and spooky game.
Yeah.
So... So I push this, right?
I push this.
And then... Okay.
I push this door.
And...
And I am like... What do I... Okay.
And then this... This... And then...
And then this guy comes down.
And I am like...
What the fuck do I do with you?
What?
No!
Okay.
Usually... Usually it doesn't pick me up that fast.
Usually I have a few times to process him.
Okay.
So...
What I think... I am thinking...
I think I am stuck on this guy for a bit.
Thank you guys.
Thank you all for the follows.
Thank you Link for the follow too.
Have a blood heart as well.
And we got a lot of art done Poki.
I... I have been playing this game for only 20 minutes and I am only... I am already 90% done.
Isn't that crazy?
Isn't that fucking crazy?
Don't... Don't trust what my...
Don't trust what my...
What my Twitch says.
I have only been playing this game for 20 minutes.
And I am already like 90% done with this game.
Isn't that crazy Poki?
I am so fucking good.
Fucking speed running.
I hope you are alive.
Well thank you.
Thank you.
Oh.
Come on.
He is coming.
He doesn't know.
Please.
Yeah.
That's right you little bitch.
Okay.
I need to pick up the shoe.
And then...
And then... And then throw the shoe.
Throw.
Oh my god.
Please.
Don't be weak.
Don't be weak right now.
Please.
I need you to throw the shoe.
No.
Oh my god.
Is the shoe too big?
The shoe is too big.
Please.
I picked the wrong shoe.
I am sorry.
Please.
Okay.
We got this.
I am leaving.
Goodbye.
Yeah.
I can't catch you now.
Okay.
So the problem was that I picked...
I picked the wrong shoe.
But we are okay now.
We are okay now.
We are okay.
We are okay chat.
Well, I guess it's exactly...
Oh!
We were never stuck on it.
This was my first try playing this.
Doing that quiz.
Yeah.
Never.
Exactly.
First try.
Hiram!
Okay.
What the fuck is this piano doing here?
Boom.
Oh.
I got it.
I thought I tied there.
Okay.
Can I open this?
No.
Wait.
If I can just...
I can just climb on all of these, right?
Yeah.
Let me just climb on these.
Okay.
But what do I do after?
Oh.
Push?
No.
What the fuck?
Oh.
I can climb on this.
Just grow taller.
Shit.
You're right.
I can climb on this.
Wait.
There's a door.
Push?
No.
Okay.
Climb.
Just grow taller.
Fuck.
You're right.
Oh.
I...
I can just climb this.
Okay.
Boom.
Oh.
Wait.
It's pulling me?
Am I getting pulled?
No.
I'm supposed to jump here.
I'm just gonna climb.
Oh.
Stupid.
There's a...
Oh.
No.
Can I...
Whoa.
Get your hands away from here.
Because I'm on a data and my powers out, but I hope I have nicer lights than you tonight.
Okay.
Oh thank you.
Thank you.
You stopped me.
Oh.
I Thank you, I really do appreciate it.
Oh, isn't this game like 3 hours maximum?
So I'm planning on playing this game for 3 hours.
Playing this game for the rest of the stream.
And then we're gonna play a new game tomorrow.
Cause I heard this was only 3 hours.
Or 4 hours max.
Have a monkey.
Wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Oh, no wait, wait.
Let me back up, let me back up.
I have an idea.
I do this, and I go...
Ugh.
Yeah, you don't know where I am.
Oh, oh, wait!
Wait!
Yeah, you don't know where I am.
Stupid.
Wait, wait.
Please, please.
Let me through.
Let me through here.
No!
You stupid.
What do I do here?
How do I get out though?
What?
How do I get out of here?
Wait.
I'm so confused.
What game were you thinking?
I'm thinking I'm playing Visage.
How do I...
What do I do with you?
What?
How do I get out?
Let me out!
Cause I was watching you run away from him.
I don't know how to get out, chat.
I don't know how to get out.
Chat.
Ugh.
Oh, there's a door.
Oh, I can't push it.
Never mind.
I thought I could get out.
Okay.
I got an idea.
I got...
Okay.
Not like that.
Okay, so I have this.
But I don't know what to do with this.
Can I throw you?
I can't even throw you.
What the fuck?
What's the point?
Who the fuck would do that?
What?
Okay, wait, okay, okay, I'll figure this out.
I'll use musing.
Maybe make the guy open.
Oh shit, you're right!
You're so smart Rem!
You're so fucking smart!
Okay, where the fuck is this thing?
Okay, I'm gonna put this here.
I'm gonna put you here.
And then... okay, Bunny will figure out like how we're to hide though afterwards.
Because I swear if they make me do this again afterwards...
Okay, where's a good hiding spot?
Should I hide here?
I should hide here, right?
Okay, maybe if I hide here... Oh!
Oh my god!
Thank you so much for the follow rock!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a... have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
What you gonna do?
Bam!
I thought I would make more noise.
I honestly...
thought this would make a lot more noise.
Come on.
Make some noise.
Huh?
Oh TV!
Oh!
Oh TV make noises!
Please, please.
Let me... let me... let me...
Let me hide.
Let me hide in here.
This is dope.
Open the door!
He doesn't know... he doesn't know.
He is stupid.
Fuck.
Aww, he wants a girlfriend.
He wants like... Oh, wait Ryan?
Oh.
Ah!
You liar!
Why did you tell me to run?
Why did you tell me to run??
Shz alliance Wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, you're right.
I should run!
Please!
Let me through!
He doesn't know!
He didn't know.
I just wanted to ask how you laughed.
Oh, you're just a pro for letting people know when to run.
God, I'm so good at this game.
Please.
Oh, God!
I thought I was gonna make it.
Boom!
Look at that shit.
Please try.
Okay.
Okay, let me through.
Please, let me through.
Where am I?
We haven't hit the kitchen yet.
The kitchen is part of the fat boy, right?
The fat kitchen guy.
He's in this game, right?
I don't know if he's in this game or like...
Or like in the DLC because I've seen that guy a lot.
Open.
Open?
Oh!
I pushed!
I need to... Oh!
Oh!
What?
I got past the first time.
How did I die there?
What the fuck?
Let me pass the first time.
Yeah, but I got past it the first time.
So, I thought I was okay.
Okay.
And then I go this?
What?
Boom!
Kare-chan is so smart.
And then...
Wait.
Oh!
What the f- What the f- How?
How?
How is that possible?
What's the f-
What the f- Oh my god.
What happened to the room?
So what's your favorite...
What's your favorite part about this game?
I don't know.
I guess the atmosphere is really- I like the atmosphere of this.
It's not spooky though.
It's not like...
I guess there's parts where I scream but it's not like damn I'm spooked.
Please!
No!
I couldn't climb.
I couldn't climb just then.
But... but...
Okay.
Alright.
We... we opened the door.
Okay.
Please.
Please don't...
I'm holding onto it this time.
I...
I don't know why I live there.
I don't know.
I don't even know how far we are in this game right now.
Oh yeah!
I heard that.
I heard there's also DLC too.
But we're not playing the DLC after this.
We're just gonna try and finish this one.
This one.
I wanna finish this for a two day stream.
What the fuck!
Wrong way.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah bitch!
That's very stupid.
Get your hand away.
Dude how long is he gonna...
Holy God.
Thank you so much for the follow, Tashi.
thank you.
Thank you.
Oh I just have to run when he puts his hand up like that.
Okay.
Stupid.
Is this a kitchen?
Oh!
Please!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No.
Yeah, stupid.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, why is your hand so long?
Why is your hand so long?
Please!
That's stupid.
Wait, wait, no!
He still got me.
How was I supposed to know?
No!
How do I get out of the game?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Stupid.
Oh, no, don't touch me.
No, climb again!
Yeah, yeah, I know now.
I know now.
Hurry up!
Hurry up and slam it!
Slam it!
Please!
I don't know how long I can do this!
I don't know how long...
Holy shit, how strong is this thing?
Please, no!
No!
Is it not gonna close?
Am I gonna do this forever?
Wait, I think...
I don't think this is...
I don't think this is what I'm supposed to do, guys.
I don't think...
I don't think this is what I'm supposed to do.
I don't think it's ever gonna break.
I just realized that thing's not gonna break ever.
Okay.
What do I do here?
I'm looking up.
I'm looking up respectfully.
Do I...
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
What do I do?
I'm just doing this over and over again.
I...
I don't know...
I don't know what to do!
Ah...
Don't touch me!
Is this?
No!
What am I doing?
You're in the middle, pull that.
How though?
How do I pull this?
I can't pull this at all!
I can't... I can't pull anything!
What do I pull?
What do I... Oh!
This.
Do I pull you?
No, no!
He's gonna pick me!
No!
Okay, wait...
Okay, I know now.
I know now.
Okay,
okay.
My brain is working.
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm figuring it out.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm trying chat!
Oh no!
Yeah!
Stupid!
Wait, there's more?
Oh shit, there's more!
I celebrated too early.
That was nice of them to know there was more.
Come on, come on, come on!
Yeah, stupid!
Stupid!
You see that?
Oh, wait!
His arm's still grabbing me!
Yeah...
Stupid...
Yeah, I'm so smart.
I'm so smart.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
What's he gonna do now?
What are you gonna do now, huh?
I'm deep banging his arm.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Yeah, progress.
We're making progress.
The lair.
Ooh.
Sounds spooky.
You crippled that guy?
Dude, he deserves it.
He deserves it.
That's what you get for getting long arms.
Just be like the rest of us.
We're short arms.
Alright, really let me hydrate.
Cause I feel like I won't be able to hydrate later.
Holy shit, my arm broke there.
Alright.
Hopefully no more creepy-ass monsters.
What am I saying?
They're all scary as hell.
We haven't seen the...
We haven't seen the chef yet.
Yeah, I guess what he's...
I thought that was him.
I thought that was the creepy-ass chef.
Creepy guy.
Did I grab onto this?
Oh I do.
Wee.
There's the chef!
There he is!
I see you!
I know you're next.
I remember the chef being the next boss.
Oh!
Doo doo doo doo doo.
Oh I'm hungry again.
Oh no.
I'm hungry.
Just eat those bodies here.
Isn't this meat?
Why can't you eat this?
I don't understand.
Just open it.
Meat is meat.
Look he's trying to figure out this game is the best thing ever.
Oh my god.
Eating people now.
The chef always creeps out.
He's haunted my nightmares several times.
Oh shit.
Is he creepier than long boy?
How can he be creepier than long boy?
Yeah I'm gonna eat ya.
I'm gonna eat ya.
Yeah that's right.
Yeah.
Wait I'm not eating this?
Oh okay.
I thought I was gonna eat the rat.
I thought I was gonna...
Wait I do?
I do?
Why wouldn't you let me eat him?
Let me eat you.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Um.
Stupid rat.
See he'll...
Kinda sad.
It's pretty sad.
Like.
Poor rat.
Why did I join in?
Oh she just ate a rat.
Raw.
She could've at least cooked it.
I guess I've never ate rats.
Apparently you can eat cooked rats in somewhere in the world.
Um.
Food is food.
Can I push this?
I push you.
Oh.
What?
What the hell?
It won't let me in.
It pushed me back.
At least you're not hungry anymore.
Yeah.
It's a ratty rat world here.
Do do do do do do.
Do do.
Oh.
Let me up.
What?
What's that?
Oh that's the chef.
That's the chef.
There he is.
Oh you're ugly!
I just used my new channel.
I only put the reasoner back on.
Dude I don't...
What the hell...
What do you mean?
Look at...
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Why are you screaming?
What the fuck?
He's screaming so I scream too.
Maybe it's because you're still alive.
I was like, why are you screaming?
Why scream at you?
I look like a running banana.
How do I do this?
He doesn't know.
He's stupid.
He just wants to consume.
Maybe I don't run.
Maybe that's the play here.
Maybe I just don't run.
Can I hide here?
I look.
I am looking respectfully.
Where do I hide here though?
I hide.
Can't see me, you stupid.
Where do I hide there though?
I don't know where to hide.
Okay, where do you go?
Where do you go?
You guys want to see his face?
I mean...
I can't move away.
You hide in his belly.
I look respectfully.
I'm looking respectfully at him.
How come he has hair?
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Oh shit, no he doesn't have hair.
He just ripped his... That's not his skin.
Oh!
He doesn't know!
You don't know!
No!
I can't get it!
How did you do?
I couldn't slide.
Okay.
I have to do this again.
I hate this.
Admiral, thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you!
Have a butter!
Okay.
I'm looking respectfully.
I go...
I'm sorry.
Please.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
Go.
Here you go.
Alright.
I'm looking respectfully at him.
Okay.
Oh my...
Oh!
No!
You don't know!
What?!
How?!
How does he know?
Yeah.
He doesn't.
He doesn't know.
I'm looking respectfully.
He had a cut feeling.
Oh my god.
I don't know how to do this one.
Make a break for it.
The last time I did that, I got cut!
Go here?
Don't get cut.
Looking respectfully.
That's my strategy.
I'm a very respectful person.
You bitch.
Looking respectfully.
What?!
Looking!
Looking respectfully!
Looking...
How?!
I'm a respectful person!
I'm respecting you!
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
Okay, I need to know his...
What is he doing?
Cutting some fishies.
Okay.
Alright.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know that's my heart.
Going ba dum ba dum ba dum.
He doesn't know.
Yeah, he's stupid.
Stupid.
Look it up.
There's a key?!
Where the fuck do I get the key?!
Okay.
This is how I do it.
Oh, it's on him!
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
I just need to knock him out.
Right?
That's all I have to do.
I'm gonna knock you out.
God, if I die here, I have to do this all over again.
I don't wanna die!
I don't wanna redo this!
I don't wanna keep looking!
What's over there?
What is this?
Okay...
Oh!
What?!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck was that?!
What?!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck did I just do?
He's a motherfucker!
Shit...
What the fuck?
That actually scared me.
What do I do here?
Oh shit, hey.
Yeah.
What are you?
What is this?
Wait.
Wait, where am I?
Hey, Ray.
I don't know what I did.
I actually don't know what I did.
Is this a checkpoint?
Oh, key.
Key.
Who are you?
No, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
That's a no.
You don't know.
You don't know?
Oh, he knew.
He knew.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry for waking you up.
Can we tell them where it is?
How the heck did you do that?
Okay.
Oh shit.
That's why they're double toilets!
They're twins!
Is that what twins do?
Do you guys poop with each other?
Are there any twins in chat?
Is this why there are any twins in chat?
Is that what you guys do?
We have toilets next to you?
Why else is there like double toilets?
You guys poop next to each other like that.
Look, look, see?
Any twins in chat?
I'm a twin in depth.
Are you hiding?
Fool, you don't have to lie to us.
We don't have to...
Is this a solid logic?
Well, you don't have to lie to us.
Don't worry.
It's our little secret.
Don't worry fool.
What if he poots but he needs two toilets?
Woo!
He don't know.
Stupid.
Okay.
Where did he go?
Okay, all right, all right.
We go down.
Boom.
I'm so fucking smart.
He didn't fucking know.
Stupid twin.
He's the stupid twin, clearly.
Okay, now I have to do this again.
Now I have to do this again.
No!
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Can I go under here?
I can.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm looking respectfully.
I'm looking very respectfully right now.
Okay.
Stupid bitch, you stupid bitch, you stupid bitch.
No, no!
No, no he doesn't know, he doesn't know!
He doesn't know I'm here!
Stupid fucking n'om.
He doesnt knol.
Stupid.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, please, get in, get in the key, get in the key.
Get in, get in, get in, get in!
With?
Where?
Why did I pick up the log?
Why did I pick up the log this late?
Let me in!
Wait!
Let me out!
Okay.
I'm late.
Where do I go?
Jump.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, meat.
Cr-crimbo-crimbo-yut-to-you-you.
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Oh shit, I'm making some sausages.
Thank you so much, Hamil Bloodheart.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Meat.
No more meat.
Do I keep doing this?
No.
What is this?
Bye?
I can't-
You know, she's- she's under, but you can't duck since that requires energy.
Okay.
Alright.
I need to get this meat in.
How do I put more sausages?
More sausages, please.
Wee.
...
Alright, alright.
Alright.
No, no, no?
G-get in.
Get in the hole.
...
Is it Arby's?
Welcome to Arby's.
Alright.
Boop.
Okay.
And then I just do the turn turn.
And then... oh my god it looks like poop.
I'm so uncomfortable.
Is this enough?
Okay I need more.
That made it look so...
Oh shit I can pick up a sausage.
Oh my god this looks so fucking wrong.
Thank you so much for the follow, Rubio.
Thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
That little butt heart.
Okay, we go up.
Mystery meat is the best when you meet.
How do I get more... more... more meat?
I need more.
More!
Okay I can't fucking climb clearly.
I need more meat.
Give me!
Give... oh what the fuck?
Give... give me!
Oh!
Wait.
Did I fuck up?
What?
How do I...
How... brain.
Okay clearly it's not that thing.
Cause I can't get on top of it.
So...
What the fuck do I do?
Do I...
fuck it?
Do I move you bucket?
You bucket?
Bucket?
No, no bucket.
What the fuck?
Should be enough?
Okay let me try again.
Maybe I climb.
Oh it won't let me churn more meat.
Meat.
Oh.
Are you sure it's enough dude?
I don't think it's enough guys.
Can I climb?
Climb.
No it keeps making me make more meat.
I need two more sausages.
Where do I... do I... I'm gonna bring you with me.
Maybe if I bring you with me.
Okay no.
I'll go back up.
I'm gonna go back up.
I need one more.
Wait can I go over here?
Oh!
There's a little hole here.
Oh hey.
Uh.
We're in.
I'm so smart.
Look at that.
Oh.
What are you?
Oh shit.
Fucking foul.
Okay how do I get up here?
God damn it!
I'm so...
Okay.
Please!
Let me up here!
I don't know how to get up!
Okay.
Okay that's not it.
Up.
Please let me up!
Let me up!
How do I get up?
Zara!
Thank you so much for gifting us stuff to Acer!
Thank you!
Woo!
Can I get some bright nights real quick for...
for...
Zara and Acer?
And that's a best time to eat while watching this.
I see.
It's okay.
God damn it!
Get me up!
Please!
Please let me up!
Let me up!
I don't know how to get up here!
Okay.
I keep jumping.
Maybe...
Okay I... I... I...
Clearly jumping was not the...
was not the right idea.
Ow...!
How do we get up?
I'm... I'm angry.
Okay.
Maybe...
Maybe this will work again.
Maybe this will work.
Alright.
No.
Okay.
Now that...
The meat?
I can't get to this meat though.
There's no meat here.
Like, it won't let me pick up the meat here.
Ugh!
It won't let me pick up I'm trying to give up!
Let me make you into sausages!
Fire!
Is it fire?
Fire?
I don't know what to do.
Okay, I give up.
Clearly this isn't it.
I don't think this is it, chat.
I don't think this was the right idea.
Wait, can I pull this?
Wait, is that me?
Wait, this is me!
You're fucking... you're all blind!
You're all blind!
We're all blind!
We're all fucking blind!
We're so stupid!
We're all stupid!
This wasn't...
We were all... We were all stupid.
It's okay.
NINTEND!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
I hope you had a good stream!
What were you... What were you streaming?
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Hello everyone!
Hi!
We're playing Little Nightmares!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I hope you had a really good stream, Nintend!
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Sludgy Gamer!
And Unravel Persona, thank you, thank you.
Have a... Have a Bud Hearts!
Thank you so much, guys!
And Dutch Potato, thank you!
Okay, I'm trying to... Little Nightmares is so good, yeah!
We're using our brains right now.
We've been trying to find this last piece of meat for like 20 years!
And it...
It was right here!
It was looking... It was looking...
It was right here the last reason we didn't know.
So we were having some problems.
We were all stupid.
Chad and I were both stupid together.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Fish and Super Joshi.
Thank you, thank you.
Have some, have some buttharts.
I'm not blind.
I've seen the game before.
Everyone's like, yeah, just go up.
Just go up.
That's how you do it.
And I'm like, up?
Up?
I keep fucking trying to get up and it wasn't working.
All right, some sausages.
Let's go.
Yeah, you know, up.
Yeah, up.
Clearly I was at the wrong up.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh, this isn't real true.
The movie's simple.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
We've only been playing this game for like 20 minutes and already 90% done.
Isn't that crazy?
Guys, for all you new viewers out there, we're making a new world record.
Also, do not trust the timestamp of my stream because it's broken right now.
But I've only been playing it for 20 minutes.
Yeah, it's a speedrun.
I'm gonna fucking...
Guinness World Records right here.
Little nightmares.
First try.
Blind run.
Yeah, it's only 20 minutes.
But it says to... no, no.
It says... it's... it's... the zero... the zero is 23.
Sorry, I meant 23 minutes.
I...
The zero is at the wrong place.
It's bugged right now.
She has a 3D mod.
She's even using some kind of dice for hand cat...
Yeah, yeah, I have a hand tracker.
So, trying to convince you that you're better playing games than getting your emos done.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Where is this key?
Okay.
What the fuck am I doing?
Where's the key?
Look.
See this tech?
I'm bee-hopping.
This is some like... a speedrun tech right here.
My bee-hops.
Look at that.
Okay, where the hell the fuck do I...
Oh, there's a switch here.
I was like...
Where is the key?
OH!
WHAT THE FUCK!
WHOA!
GET OUT!
Oh, no!
No!
Yeah, but it's a broken tip.
Okay.
Alright.
Anyway, I was...
I was fucking... Anyway, what happened?
I passed out for a second.
Uh...
I don't know what happened.
I just...
I just passed out for a second.
Anyway, this is a speedrun.
This is a speedrun, guys.
Oh, I'm running now.
I know now.
Can't see me, stupid.
Oh...
Get away!
Jeez.
Please leave.
It's stupid.
Yeah!
Oh, let me... let me through.
Let me through.
Wait!
Why can't I get out?
Please!
Oh, my God.
Please leave.
Okay.
He doesn't know.
Oh!
Is this...
Do you think... Do you think he can't see me?
If I hide here, he can't see me if I hide here?
I'm such a good speedrunner.
I am so fast.
Look at this.
Oh, gross.
That's disgusting.
He doesn't know.
Oh...
Oh!
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Thank you so much for the follow, Final Boss.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
It's stupid.
Okay.
I don't know what his pattern is going to be.
I'm just going to look at him for a bit.
Just in case.
I need...
I don't want to go out right now.
I'm too scared.
I don't want to redo this whole thing.
I don't want to redo it.
He wants to do HR...
HR... stuff.
But extra meaty.
What's he doing?
Is he not going to turn around?
Oh, he's just going to keep chopping meat.
Okay.
I'm... I'm flying.
Bye.
Oh, I do the grinder.
Please.
No.
No, no, no.
Please.
Let me get the key.
Let me go.
Can't you run faster?
You little child.
Okay.
Please run faster, child.
Please.
Run faster.
The key.
Ah.
Child, please.
Oh.
He can't see me.
He doesn't know.
He's stupid.
You're stupid.
Please.
He's stupid.
He doesn't know.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alright.
He didn't know.
He likes critical information.
He's a fucking idiot.
What do I do after?
I don't even...
What the fuck do I...
Oh, here.
Okay.
Look at that.
See?
Fucking easy.
So easy.
I wasn't scared at all.
What the fuck do I...
Is this a plunger?
Do I...
Do I pick you up?
What the fuck?
Oh, I climb.
I'm my home.
Okay.
No.
That's not what I do.
What the fuck do I do here?
Oh.
I climb.
I do climb.
There's a hole here.
No, he freaks out and then he solves the date.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do here now.
I'm just gonna...
He's doing dishes.
Oh, they are twins!
Look at that!
I told you guys!
That's why they had two toilets.
Because twins poop next to each other.
That's what twins do.
That's what this game taught me.
Oh.
I'm supposed to go here.
Okay.
I have to...
Can I get out from here?
He doesn't know.
There's another stupid...
They know nothing.
I'm so confident.
I'm gonna drink some tea while I watch them.
They know nothing.
They don't know shit.
Stupid.
Okay, where do I...
Oh!
No!
Oh, he doesn't know.
They don't know.
Like, you idiots.
I just ran through glass.
I was like, oh, fuck.
No, he doesn't know.
I can't.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
They can smell fear.
I hear nothing.
What are you guys talking about?
I don't feel shit.
Okay.
What does this do?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh...
Oh, oh...
Oh, oh, oh...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh...
Oh, oh, oh...
Are you an idiot?
Okay, what the fuck do I do after...?
Wait.
Why is he looking under the table?
You're not supposed to do that.
What do I do here after?
Can I go up?
Up!
Not up.
What?
How do I?
I'm so confused!
Here?
What the fuck?
What do you want me to do?
I...
I don't know what to do!
What do I do?
I just turned it on but now I don't know what's next after.
Uh huh.
The door?
Oh, door.
Wait, there's a door here.
Okay, okay.
We're waiting.
We're waiting for this freak to get out.
Please leave.
Please leave, mister.
Go back to the... in the other kitchen.
I don't trust!
I don't know if I can trust you guys.
Door!
Okay.
Okay, it was not the door.
Why won't it let me go up?
Wait, what?
I can turn it again?
What the fuck?
I'm so confused.
How do I get to the hooks though?
How do I get up to you?
You're so tall!
I don't wanna do this again!
I need to...
Okay, I gotta...
I'll make it past here.
Stupid.
I'm gonna hide here.
Okay.
Alright.
Where is this hook leading to?
Okay.
Oh, it's scary!
They think it's like a little bitzer hunt!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm looking.
I'm looking respectfully.
I'm looking respectfully!
The dish tower!
Oh, there's a dish tower.
I was like, what dish tower?
I'm looking respectfully!
Please leave.
Leave.
Leave!
Oh my god.
Why you keep washing your dishes?
Just buying new plates?
How do I get up?
How do I go up?
I'm getting up.
No!
Please!
Stupid!
You can't get me!
I don't know.
What you gonna do?
Huh?
Nothing.
Oh!
Wait!
No!
He
doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
Wait!
What!
That's freaking idiot!
That's so good...
That's great...
Did he put a bottle on you?
The fear of trying to do that again The fear of trying to do that again Made me fucking love...
Made me like speedrun that shit.
I did not want to do that again.
What is it?
I did not want to wait again.
I didn't want to fucking wait and hide again.
Why wash dishes when you just buy new ones?
Exactly!
You know what the biggest brain is?
Just buy paper plates and then recycle them when you're done.
Like, you never have to do dishes.
You just recycle your plates afterwards.
Isn't that so smart?
Look at that.
I'm bee hopping.
That run felt like a Super Bowl touchdown run.
Holy shit.
Convenient ladder.
No, right?
That seagull?
Holy shit!
Is that land?
Oh no, that's just boats.
Look at them.
Look at it.
That's a boat.
And then another boat.
There they go.
Look at them.
Look at the cattle.
I was trying to get him onto it.
How was I supposed to know I did it?
Okay.
Please let me get him onto it.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Okay.
Clearly.
Wait.
Okay.
This time I can do it.
Maybe.
Wait.
No.
I know you're supposed to touch this.
What else are you supposed to do?
See?
I just didn't know.
I just didn't know my directions.
I was just blind.
I don't fucking know.
I just didn't know my directions clearly.
Here.
I'm so... Holy shit!
How big is this ship?
I think it's a big ass boat.
Dead Procession.
Yeah.
Oh look.
There's a seagull.
Hey there.
Look at the size of a seagull.
Look at him.
Look at him over there.
Ha!
Look at him.
Jesus Christ.
They're big boys.
They're like big boys.
Where the fuck is this game?
Dude.
I don't even know.
Farseer.
I've... We've been playing this game for like 20 minutes and I still don't know.
I still don't know what we're doing.
I...
I jumped and freaked out.
Because I didn't know there was shit below me.
Speedrunner skipping the cut...
Wait there were cutscenes?
No it was just like a fucking chonkers.
Look at them.
Look at these chonkers.
Almost detect to far.
There's a really good theory I still won't share because spoilers.
It's been 20 minutes, 30 minutes ago.
Sorry I meant 23 minutes.
Sorry.
I meant 23 minutes guys.
I've been playing this game for 23 minutes and I still don't know what we're doing.
Oh shit look at her.
She's the only non-chonky one.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
I was too busy looking at her.
Thank you socials for following me.
Thank you.
Have a butter.
I'm sorry.
I blinked for a second.
I blinked for a second chat.
I'm sorry.
So anyway I haven't died yet.
I was just blinking.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh shit.
Sorry chat.
I passed out for a second.
What happened?
I don't know what happened.
Anyway, zero deaths.
I passed out for a second.
Anyway, sorry about that.
I keep forgetting.
I'm trying to do bee hopping and I keep forgetting that there's like a gap here.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
I was distracted by girl.
Yeah, girl distracted me.
Do I get up here?
Oh, I get up here.
Look at them chonkers.
Oh lady.
Boom!
Dude, look at the speedrun!
Look at that!
I'm gonna look at them too.
Oh, where are they going?
Where are you going?
Damn, look at the wrinkles down there.
They're the one rocking the ship.
True.
Oh shit, they're eating.
What the fuck?
He looks like a rat.
Look at him.
Prepare to run?
What?
No!
I don't wanna run again.
Oh!
Please!
Where do I go?
Oh wait, up!
Up, up, up, up, up!
Up, up, up, up, up, up!
Fucking idiot.
Hey, what the fuck?
Oh, you fucked up so bad you still live.
I know.
I don't know how the fuck I survived that.
Stupid.
What you gonna do?
Grab me?
Oh my god, please don't grab me.
Please don't grab me.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Fucking idiot.
What do I do here?
Don't eat the walking cheese.
I'm trying to figure out what to do here.
Cause I don't wanna go climb that and then get fucking eaten.
What the fuck?
Did that chair move?
Is it here?
What am I doing?
What the fuck?
I'm just so entertaining.
Misa, thank you so 100,000 fans.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Are you good?
Glad you're enjoying this stream.
Misa, I'm glad, I'm glad.
Okay.
Where do I go though?
That's the thing.
Let me up!
Okay, clearly that's not it.
Okay.
Gotta run down the table, huh?
Wait, why is there a chair here?
Oh, stupid.
I just pushed the chair.
Oh, never mind.
That was a dead end.
That was just a stupid fucking achievement.
Oh, I hugged?
I hugged him!
What the fuck?
Why do I need to hug you?
Can I throw you off?
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna give it to you.
I'm bringing you with me.
Wait, I can feed him?
I'm gonna feed him.
But...
Oh, I can't feed him.
Alright, I guess you're just gonna watch me die.
I guess you're just gonna watch me die.
I'm a fucking random ass.
No.
Wait.
Let me up.
Let me up!
Okay.
What do I do?
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Have a good heart.
Thank you.
Climb the chair maybe?
Ha ha ha ha.
Like an idiot.
Look at him!
Look at him.
He just eats it and then- and then it comes back out.
Look at that.
Do do do do do!
Do do do do!
Ah!
Okay,
that wasn't it.
That wasn't it.
Okay, anyway, here we go again.
Here we go again.
I'm supposed to dodge them while trying.
Look at that.
Oh, maybe if I do bee hops.
I'm gonna do bee hops.
That's it, that's it.
We're gonna use the tech.
We're gonna use the...
the little nightmares tech that we learned.
Look at this.
Look at that.
Yeah!
Oh!
This is it!
No!
This wasn't it!
We're so close!
The bee hop tech!
We know what to do now.
We know what to do.
It's the bee hops.
Zero deaths.
Yeah, it's been 24 minutes and we haven't died yet.
Isn't that crazy, guys?
You think?
Yeah.
Yeah!
Look at that!
Oh, shit!
I knew learning bee hops was gonna save me.
Look at that.
That's what you have to do, just bee hop.
That's amazing.
Can't believe how amazing, pretty, and incredible you are.
I know!
Isn't that crazy, guys?
That was a pretty cash money move of you.
That's what bee hop taught me.
I knew bee hopping would be...
would help me sooner or later.
I knew it.
Can I eat my bread?
You're always hungry.
Just eat now.
Well, when he had... when he had... when she had food, she fucking doesn't eat it.
I'm a spoiled bitch.
You kept, like, starving and eating, like, live rats and everything, too.
And now that she has real food, she's like, no.
Fucking oh.
Dude, this ASMR of, like, them eating is like... I don't know how I feel about it.
They're like...
It's like ASMR.
This game makes me many things hungry.
It's not one of them.
Can I go over here?
Oh, shit.
I can go over here.
What am I gonna do here, though?
What does he want me to do here?
Whoa!
Wait!
I don't wanna be here anymore!
Please!
Let me!
Let me go!
You idiot.
Stupid.
Do I jump over him?
Oh my god, why are you so fast?
That procession.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No!
Not you!
Leave me alone!
Get out of here.
Toilet!
He doesn't know.
Leave me alone!
Toilet paper.
TP, I need to hug it for comfort.
Okay, I have to go up here.
How do I?
How do I go up?
Okay, not like that.
True horrors if he starts pooping.
Oh my god.
I do not need that ASMR right now.
I do not need the poop ASMR from this game.
How do they flush?
They don't have any flushers.
Pull a Banjo-Kazooie and go down the toilet tree.
Oh!
He's hiding with the paper.
Not like he grabbed it and wiped his ass with.
Okay, okay.
I think I have to do this, right?
Okay, no.
That skin looks like a bath.
Boom.
Thank you so much for the follow shadows!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a... have a fun heart.
Thank you so much.
Do I push?
Door.
Door!
No, not door.
Hello, fuck.
Can I climb up?
Can I climb you up?
No.
Oh shit!
No, wait, no, wait.
I don't know what to do.
Stuck inside.
I don't know.
Just leaving?
I can't!
Look!
Wait.
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Toilet paper.
Up.
Oh my god.
This is where I live now.
I guess...
I guess I live here now.
Break the mirror?
How the fuck do I break the mirror?
Boom.
Oh, please.
Let me out.
Oh no.
Can?
Oh!
He gave me a can from earlier!
He gave me a can!
Oh, fush.
Okay.
Okay, maybe... maybe... wait, wait, wait.
Maybe it's not the can.
Maybe... wait, okay, okay, okay.
Ah!
Okay, maybe not.
Okay.
Oh!
Shit!
I broke the can!
I broke the mirror!
I'm sorry!
Okay, open the door.
Open the door.
Oh.
Oh, do I just go on the other side?
Okay.
I thought he was gonna come back.
Had some laughs, so catch you later.
I'll go get that one on the record.
Alright, that's the scene.
Thank you so much for hanging out with us tonight.
I hope you have a good night's rest.
Thank you for hanging out with us.
I didn't think that would work either.
I thought we were supposed to...
I thought we were supposed to break the mirror.
And then like the guy would like make noise and stuff.
And then...
And then... And then... The guy would like...
open the door and get out.
I didn't know that was another room.
I thought that was just...
I actually didn't think that was another room.
Oh shit, sorry.
My thingy is being weird.
Let me recalibrate.
Okay, there we go.
Have a good rest of the stream.
Alright, all dear.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I really do appreciate it.
Hope you have a good rest of the day.
Alright, let me...
Let's...
Where the fuck is he?
Oh, he's chopping.
He's eating the chop chop.
Chop chop chop.
Yeah, that's not gonna fuck me over.
Right?
Did I go down?
Ha!
I don't deserve here.
Why are you running away from...
Dude, you're scaring...
Look how ugly they are!
That's why.
They're freaks.
Doki's intelligence scares me.
I know I'm so smart.
I know.
It scares me too, how smart I am sometimes.
What?
Leave me alone.
No!
Just keep running.
Just keep running straight.
Oh no!
Now it's down.
Now it's down!
What?
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I'm tired.
Okay, clearly we don't keep going straight.
We don't keep running straight.
I have learned that it's just not only straight.
It's not just straight.
It's down too.
It's also down.
Alright, I'm not...
Alright, I got this.
Oh, please don't touch me.
Don't touch me.
Okay, okay.
Down.
The bee hop.
Oh my god.
Get out.
Yeah.
What you gonna fucking...
Ah!
No!
Bee hop.
Bee hop!
No!
Please!
Oh my god!
Ah!
No!
Oh my god.
The bee hop.
He's like, idiot.
The bee hop is amazing.
That's right.
Alright.
Let me look at him.
Oh, they're just eating now.
The fuck?
It's hard to end stream think about what just happened.
They're just chillin'.
What a bunch of Oh,
they're just chillin'.
Oh my god!
Psire!
Thank you so much for gifting a sub to Admiral!
Thank you.
Woo!
Can't get some dangerous to quick feet PSIRE and Admiral for put the looking sub...
OK...
Okay, I...
Break the doll.
Where's the doll?
Shit, did I forgot about the doll?
I forgot about the doll.
I thought there was a doll here.
Is it back there?
Oh no!
I forgot!
Let me back in!
It won't let me back in!
It's closed!
We don't need this stupid doll.
Oh shit, I need it.
Are you hungry?
How could you be hungry?
There was food everywhere!
Stupid girl!
How are you hungry?
There was so much food!
I died from hunger after not- Oh, you stupid idiot.
There was so much food.
There was food everywhere.
Yeah, fuck this gnome.
Fuck this gnome!
Feed me!
Oh!
What?
Well, I was fed.
Thank you so much.
You're the follow.
That's...
What?
Well...
I got fed.
So...
It was not what I...
Uh...
Um...
It's not what I expected.
But I didn't...
But I got fed.
I got fed though.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Whoo!
Can I get more 4900 real quick for Sire and that's why the gifted sub.
That team I had to kill all you noticed that, didn't you?
Hahaha...
I had to...
You're running away from the monsters...
But you were the monster all along!
Oh my god, there's something wrong with this child.
What was that?
Something wrong with this child...
Hahaha!
I did not think that's what she was gonna...
Wait, there's the lady.
Lady!
Lady, it's me!
Oh.
Okay, bye lady.
Wait.
Oh, pretty lady.
Ugh.
It's my turn.
Lady!
It's me!
Alright.
Another achievement we just got.
I'm gonna drink some tea while we wait here.
Wait, is this a cutscene?
It's a cutscene.
Oh, it's not.
It's not a cutscene.
I just moved.
It was not a cutscene.
By the way.
I don't know if you've seen this game before but I'm hardly laughing right now.
Like...
I don't know if that's a good thing or a bad thing.
Um...
Okay, we go this way.
I thought it was a cutscene because it was zoomed in.
I was like just waiting.
Rolling up.
Oh, she's singing.
Hey, it's me.
Hey.
I think I died.
Okay, I didn't expect that.
I really didn't expect that.
I know.
I don't know.
I was like, hey there, lady.
Hey there.
And when she sees you, she goes on my sentence, Robert.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, closet?
Open?
Oh, no, not open.
What do you want me to do, lady?
Up?
Up.
Oh, shit, I'm so smart.
Oh, wait, I need...
What?
Up?
Oh!
What the fuck do I do, lady?
Lady, what do you want me to do, lady?
Whoa!
What the...
Okay, she didn't like that.
She...
She didn't like that when I...
She didn't like that I kept jumping up and down.
Fall down on the closet knobs?
Oh, shit.
You're right.
Let's try that.
Dumb, dumb.
Hello, original.
Well...
Ah!
Oh, shit.
Okay, I didn't jump.
I didn't jump just then.
No...
No, that wasn't it.
That wasn't it.
Also, thank you so much for the follow craze.
Thank you.
Have a...
Have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
What do I do?
Jumping.
What do you want me to do, lady?
Here?
What?
What do you want me to do, lady?
What do you want...
I can't even look at you?
Stupid lady...
Okay, I know what to do.
I know.
I like how it's like I'm sneaking into your...
Oh wait... oh wait...
Stupid lady...
I know we're just like damn...
We should like try and climb to it and then I have cramps.
Look, I have a perfectly good explanation for this.
I just... look she's pretty okay?
She's a really pretty lady.
And we haven't seen any ladies in a while.
It's been a while since we saw all these pretty ladies.
Okay.
Breaking the maze you fucking sim.
I'm sneaking.
I'm not good at stealth.
I'm bad at stealth.
I'm sorry guys.
And then she coming over.
Hello?
Lady?
To be fair we forgot it too.
Yeah, it wasn't just...
We all forgot.
We forgot it together.
Got the key.
Okay.
I don't even know what the game's about but I'm loving it so far.
I don't even know either.
I've been playing this game for like three hours already.
And I don't even... Oh wait sorry not three hours.
30 minutes already.
And I almost... I accidentally added an extra zero by mistake guys.
Do I need to keep sneaking?
I don't right?
Wait I'm gonna break you.
I'm gonna break you first.
Yeah 30 minutes.
I've been playing this game for 30 minutes.
I still don't know what the fuck we're doing guys.
Thank you so much for the follow on Serial...
Thank you thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
No butthurt yet cause I have to hold onto this key while I'm running.
So I can't give you a butthurt yet.
But I will as soon as I get to the bottom of this house.
Okay okay.
Boom.
Alright here's a butthurt for you.
Thank you thank you thank you.
Alright.
I think we're on the almost to the end too.
Lady!
I'm sorry lady!
Please!
Lady!
I'm sorry lady.
I'm sorry.
Alright so I've seen I'm not gonna help you.
She'll have one waiting for you this time.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I remember my first butthurt.
I was like, Nani, what did she say?
Oh, there's a mirror here.
Oh hey, look at this.
This is the mirror.
Do I break it?
Oh!
I'm gonna carry you.
I'm gonna carry you around.
Hey lady.
Lady!
Look, I got a mirror, lady!
Lady?
Lady!
Okay,
okay.
Where's the light?
Light!
Oh, I don't even... I'm so smart, I didn't even know.
I didn't even know!
I just wanted to carry a mirror around!
I just wanted...
I just wanted to carry a mirror around.
So fucking smart.
Where are you, lady?
Lady!
Please, lady!
Look at yourself!
Lady!
Oh shit.
Where's the light?
Where is it?
Lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady!
How many?
How much do you need to look at yourself?
How much more?
Please get up.
I'm winning.
Am I winning, son?
Am I winning?
Your health bar is high.
Oh, shi- Bye, lady.
You win.
Lady?
This is...
Why?
Why, lady?
Am I gonna eat her?
Lady?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh!
What the fuck?
I was just joking.
I ate her.
Oh my god.
What did I eat the true monster?
I was joking.
Holy...
I hate people joking.
Oh shit.
You did the worst of us.
Oh my god.
Am I lady now?
Am I the lady?
I'm lady now.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, is this gonna be a cutscene again?
But then I moved.
I knew I... I knew I was gonna have to move this time.
I am the apex predator.
Doki's the lady.
I'm the lady now.
It is I.
Oh shit.
I'm in the... Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
What?
Lady Doki.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
Yeah.
That's right.
I'm gonna fucking walk up to all of them.
Oh no.
She really is the apex predator.
What the fuck is going on?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Small people rise up.
I have no... I don't know.
I became the lady.
And now I'm consuming everyone.
Hardhacks for everyone.
Oh my god.
I'm tired.
Thank you so much for the... for the gift.
For the gift of some... some mooshikai.
Thank you.
Oh.
Wait.
Can we get some bark knights real quick for the two?
Thank you.
Thank you again!
Am I out?
I'm out.
I'm finally out.
I need some claps too.
Some claps.
Sorry.
Oh shit!
That was it!
We did it!
We fucking did it!
35 minutes.
It only took us 35 minutes.
Oh shit.
Sorry.
I mean 30 minutes.
30 minutes, zero deaths.
Dude, that has to be a world record.
That has to be a speedrun record right there.
Look at Doki Bird.
30 minutes, zero deaths.
Beehop extraordinaire.
Holy fuck.
I still don't know what the fuck just happened.
I just went...
I became the lady.
I became the lady, chat.
Lady Doki Bird the lady.
I win.
Alright, so now you're done.
You're assuming that the main character, aka Six, is the lady's daughter?
Oh shit!
I am the lady.
Yates the souls of the meat men.
I'm the lady now.
I am the lady.
Holy shit.
That was a fun game, guys.
I really had a lot of fun.
It was in...
Always a good night.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Thank you.
What horror games do you plan to play?
I think we're gonna do Visage tomorrow.
Because I wanna do like a horror game.
We're gonna do four to five horror streams before the end of October.
And I think we're gonna do Visage tomorrow.
I don't know how long Visage is, so we'll see.
We'll see.
Because I wanna do like a different horror game each stream.
So that means we're gonna play four different horror games.
Eat the lady, become the lady.
lol Are you guys familiar with how to move around the ship?
Yeah, that seems right.
That seems right.
I wanna know who the fuck were the gnomes, the gnomey gnomes.
Um, what are the games?
I don't know yet.
I'm not... I haven't decided yet.
But, um, yeah, I'm like, really honestly I decided games like two hours...
Like, I think I decided games the very last minute.
So, lol So I don't know what we're gonna do after Visage.
789 but 60 air...
Oh my god, yes.
Also that the lady wanted to be the most beautiful and made this place to make sure everyone ate too much and became fat.
Oh, so they were ugly!
So they were ugly, I knew it!
So I wasn't being mean when I called them ugly.
And she might have had an accident, hence the mask.
And while all mirrors were broken, she died due to her reflection.
Oh shit, so she was ugly too.
And she died.
I heard on Sesame Street Numbler Edition is a very scary game to play.
Which time zone are you in if you don't mind me asking?
I'm in NA, PST, Pacific Time.
Um, you weren't when you were just hungry, damn, Snickers were right all over.
Oh my gosh, um, died from ugly state.
Fuck, that's too real, man.
I didn't know that.
That's too real!
She's in no time zone, she dumps the streams.
Yeah, I stream in my own time zone.
It's my own time zone, guys.
We are gonna have to start having NA streams though, since we did hit our sub goal.
Um, our 300 sub goal.
So we're gonna have one NA stream a week, and our first NA stream is gonna be on Tuesday.
I've not decided what time yet.
Like, I need to figure out the time, so...
So I just know it's gonna be on Tuesday.
Um, it's gonna be a stream before 10pm.
That's for sure.
Patrick's prophecy, everyone's so ugly they all died.
My eyes burn when I look in the mirror too.
So in order to be human, we must eat humans.
No, in order to be a lady, you must eat the lady.
The lady said, damn, I'm gonna eat ugliness.
I'm just dying.
Oh my god.
I hope you guys had a good time.
I had a really good time too.
Um, you're the power of ugliness.
You out- ugliness.
Ugliness.
But I hope you guys had a good time, like, fucking watching me play this game.
Um, it was enough- was there 8 subs?
Was there really 8 subs?
Cause it has 304.
304.
We started with 300 though, Roy.
It was my first time here.
And, um, and that was great.
I'm glad you enjoyed the stream.
Uh, so your stream on Drunk Hour or Crackhead Hour?
Like, I don't know.
I just stream whenever, really.
I just be like, shit, I need a little stream.
And then I go be like, fuck, there- fuck, here we go.
Boo!
It is 2 AM for me.
Crimbo!
Thank you so much for the tier 1 subs!
Thank you!
Woo!
Can I have some break nights real quick for Crimbo?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, Crimbo.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys.
Holy shit.
Okay, let me count.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Um.
5.
Uh.
6, 7.
Oh shit, we did!
We did hit 8!
We can do a little giveaway!
Um, I'm gonna, yeah, I'm gonna fuck it.
Let's go, let's go.
Um.
Yeah, that's 9.
Your hair layers?
I love the stream.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you guys find it funny.
Cause I don't do a lot for- I just recently started doing more variety streams.
Cause I usually just stream art and stuff.
But, I'm glad you guys are watching.
But, apparently, people say I'm funny so they're like, you should do variety streams.
And because you're funny, it's fun to watch.
I'm like, fuck, am I?
Like, I just say, um, like, I just say like, I just say whatever comes out of my mouth.
So I never like, I, um, I never like really know what, uh, what I'm doing when I'm playing.
I usually don't stream video games.
This is like my second variety stream.
So it's like, it's like, I, I, I always get really, I get nervous about doing variety streams cause I don't know if you guys would watch it.
But I'm glad you do.
I'm glad you guys enjoy, uh, whatever I fucking say stupid shit.
I'm glad you guys have fun.
I really, I'm really happy you guys have fun about it.
Let me just pull up a tab so we can do our giveaway stuff.
Um, yeah, the music stopped cause I'm trying to, uh, trying to sell the giveaway and stuff for it.
Let's listen to the song first before I set it up cause I wanna, I'm glad I find this fun community cause it's fun.
I'm glad you have fun.
I'm glad, I'm glad you, you guys are having fun.
I'm glad you enjoyed it, Watashi.
Um, yeah, Bordo.
Oh my god.
I messed up so I never leave unless I get modded.
I love it here.
Yeah, all our mods love it here.
They, they are, they, it's not Stockholm Syndrome.
They all, they are all willingly, will, willing, willing, consensual mods.
Right?
Let me tell you guys, I love it here.
Holy shit, this is a long ass credit, see?
I bet the mods are underpaid.
Idiot, they are not even paid.
They do it out of their- They do it for free and they paid me.
And the mods paid me?
And- Look here, you see, you see, we're coming off?
We're hostages anyway so we couldn't leave if we wanted to.
I'm leaving.
Oh, you made Doki for mine.
You can never quit.
You can never... Paul's almost quit.
Paul's like...
willingly let his mod get stolen.
Only for... I don't remember who it was.
Only for Alex to give him mod back.
He wanted to like... she's gonna eat us like she ate the lady.
Yeah.
Don't make me...
Oh shit.
What's this?
Why the fu... wait, what?
Where am I?
Oh, thank you for playing.
I thought this was... I thought I could move again.
That's the funny thing that happened to Marco Player when he wanted to...
um...
Then he was using the end here.
I took so long and I ordered food.
And went to pick it up and it finished when he got back.
Oh my god.
Did we go back?
No.
Okay, we're gonna do our little giveaway.
So if you guys don't know, every time we hit...
um...
Every time we get like 8 subs, we do a little sketch giveaway for ourselves.
So basically...
um...
Um...
Acer just DM'd me.
Acer DM'd me.
Cause I'm gonna forget too.
So you should DM me about...
So every time we hit 8... we get 8 subs, we do a little sketch giveaway where I...
um...
Let... uh...
Do a little giveaway for my subs.
Where they can redeem a...
Where they can win a little sketch from me.
Um...
So yeah, let me...
Let me fucking pull this up for you guys.
Cause I keep forgetting to do it.
Okay.
Uh...
Buh buh bum.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god!
What the fuck, Jericho!
Jericho!
Holy shit!
Thank you!
Woo!
Can we get some Fortnite real quick?
For Jericho for the fucking 7 gifted subs!
Holy shit!
Okay, so we're gonna pull up 2 winners now.
We're gonna pull up 2 winners.
Thank you so much!
Jericho, thank you, thank you guys.
I really do appreciate...
The one before we were allowed to enter again.
Because I won last stream.
I think.
Yeah, yeah.
If you guys won before...
Um...
You're not eligible for the...
For the giveaway.
So...
Cause I want like everyone who has not yet won the sketch...
To...
To have a chance to win it.
So...
But you guys can enter just to see if you'll get picked.
But...
I did finish it, God.
And I just finished it.
We just finished watching the credits and everything.
So I'm just gonna...
Um...
I'm gonna fucking pull up the giveaway tab real quick, guys.
So let me...
Let me fucking pull it up for you guys.
Alright.
Where the fuck?
Where is it?
Giveaway.
There we go.
Alright.
So if you guys see your...
I'm just gonna...
Pull, pull, pull.
So...
So the...
The, the, the, the...
The, the...
I need to fucking do all this.
I need to fucking remember how to do this shit.
So you see...
The keyword is exclamation point enter.
So, um...
Just do exclamation point enter to enter the giveaway.
And the only rules is that...
Um...
All you...
Uh...
You just have to DM me on Discord if you get picked.
We're picking two winners.
Just DM me on Discord.
And, um...
It...
It can...
It's only a chibi sketch.
And it can't have...
There's no...
No over complicated designs or armor.
Cause I can't...
I can't deal with that shit.
I...
I'm too dumb for that.
Please don't.
Yes, titties!
I'll draw Bobbers!
I'll draw Big Bobbers if you want.
But just no armor and over complicated designs.
I...
I'm not strong enough, guys.
I'm not strong enough for that.
So let me...
Okay, I'm gonna do a countdown.
Ten...
Nine...
Eight...
Seven...
Six...
Five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
One...
Victor already won.
So, hahaha!
So he's like...
I'm gonna re-roll again cause Victor already won.
Or I'm trying to roll until someone who hasn't won yet gets it.
I remember I've done a sketch for Victor.
So we're gonna do another re-roll.
We're gonna do another re-roll.
Mushikai!
Congratulations!
Woo!
Just DM me on Discord of what you won for your sketch.
And...
When was this not rigged?
Mushikai got it!
They have not got the sketch before!
So it wasn't as rigged.
Okay, one more roll.
Uh, James, congratulations!
Congratulations!
Woo!
Alright.
It's not rigged today, guys!
It wasn't rigged today!
Just DM me on Discord, guys.
The winners.
The two winners.
Thank you again.
Thank you again, everyone.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate all the love and support today!
He is rigged!
You guys are amazing!
I really do appreciate it.
Not totally rigged!
Today was not a rigged day!
That's crazy!
I just consumed cotton spit today.
Alright, so...
Thank you everyone for coming to the stream.
I really do appreciate it.
We had a fun time.
I honestly had a lot of fun today.
And I really appreciate all you guys hanging out with me.
And, uh, keeping me company as we try to...
As we finish this game in 30 minutes.
It's crazy.
I know it's sad that the stream was only 30 minutes.
But hey, like...
Damn, I'm sorry that this was only a 30 minute stream, guys.
Such a short stream.
Um, what is the Discord?
Can someone do an exclamation mark on Discord?
Uh, for them real quick?
Um...
But yeah, I'm just too good at this game.
Yeah.
I was insane.
I was looking speedrunning this.
I was buddy-hopping and everything, guys.
I mean...
But yeah, guys.
Thank you everyone for the follows.
For the raids today.
For the love and support.
I really appreciate it.
I'll see you guys tomorrow for Visage.
Anyway...
Um...
Yeah.
Bye, guys!